[MUSIC]
An iPod, a phone.
[APPLAUSE]
Are you getting this?
>> Yeah.
>> Woo.
[SOUND].
>> History, we are told, is made by heroic
leaders.
[MUSIC]
>> This is a film about Leo Tolstoy's
brilliant novel War and Peace.
War and Peace is a truly magnificent
literary achievement.
It is also an extended essay, and the role
of leadership, in history.
The war of War and Peace was a conflict
between Russia and
France, culminating in the French invasion
of Russia in 1812.
The climactic battle of that
war was fought here at Borodino, not far
from Moscow.
By night fall on September 7th,
1812, some 40,000 French soldiers and
some 45,000 Russian soldiers lay dead or
wounded on this field.
They are memorialized by this monument.
This is not however, a film about French
history, or
about Russian history, it is a film about
leaders.
War and Peace argues the stories of heroic
leaders creating history are myths.
[MUSIC]
>> The main source or the movement of
history, history is determined
not by, not by the leaders, but by the
will of, of people.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Of these million.
>> Ordinary, ordinary.
>> Million of wills of ordinary people.
[MUSIC]
>> The standard catechism of leadership
proclaims that
individual leaders are vitally important
to history.
[MUSIC]
In war and peace, Napoleon and his
generals prepare for
battle, confident that their decisions
matter.
>> The moment the time arrives, you'll
attack.
Inform me when the attackers are done.
>> In St. Petersburg, we spoke with Lev
Lurry, an historian,
TV documentary producer, and professor of
political science.
Here's what he had to say, about the view
of Napoleon, found in War and Peace.
>> From his point of view, Napoleon is
also, made in historical Hollywood.
>> Mm-hm.
>> It is an actor.
It is a, I don't know, Eddie Murphy was
playing the president of
the United States, because, he by chance
[UNKNOWN].
>> Yeah.
>> It is a small student of stupid, but
very unpleasant.
>> Yeah.
>> Person who is li, loving, loving
himself more than anybody else.
Who is an actor.
>> Yes.
>> And not very good actor.
>> False actor.
[NOISE].
>> Napoleon and the Czar meet and honor
each other for their leadership.
>> [SOUND] This is a meeting too long
delayed.
>> I too am delighted.
>> We create heroic narratives about
leaders to make order out of
the chaos of history.
>> A narrative really is man's desire to
believe that there's rationality to what
happens.
And he wants a compelling storyline that
has a beginning,
a, a critical moment of choice and then a
[UNKNOWN] and
you can look at this whole thing and say
now I understand what happened and why.
And it's, it's coherent inside itself.
[SOUND].
>> This quest for coherence leads nations
to
honor their leaders with stories of
heroism and genius.
>> This striking statue in Moscow is a
[UNKNOWN] by [UNKNOWN],
one of the major Russian military leaders
in the battles described in War and Peace.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> He's represented here in a classic
heroic pose.
The basic message of War and Peace is the
such heroic portrayals and
their implicit characterization of
leadership as important in history,
is fundamentally nonsense.
They tell a good and familiar story, but
they do not describe reality.
>> Our history is inextricable the
distortion of the past.
And it's the issues that we are concerned
with today.
We go back and choose narratives to
explore.
History is politics projected into the
past.
[MUSIC]
>> Heroic stories of leadership are
standard.
>> He is also present at the President
[INAUDIBLE] White House.
>> The leadership myth is not limited to
stories of heroes.
It extends to stories of villains.
The villains of history, like the heroes,
are portrayed as producing the histories
in which they are involved.
Conceptions of leaders as making history.
>> We'll see.
>> Lead in [INAUDIBLE] to the inclination
of successful leaders to vilify and
even execute unsuccessful leaders.
>> Natasha, you write history.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah well it's, modern American
television version of history.
Are there heroes and villans in your,
histories?
>> Yeah.
In order to make a news report you
just have to have two sides.
You have a good person and a bad person
and you basically try to
analyze the story by putting them against
each other.
>> Yes.
>> In Manilla,
the United States Military Commission
hears the final witness in
the trial of Japanese General [UNKNOWN]
[UNKNOWN].
>> Is the villan, as much a myth as the
hero?
>> Madame Homma takes the stand to defend
her husband,
accused in the needless deaths of 17,000
American and
Philippine soldiers after their surrender
on the Bataan Peninsula.
>> In history, we, we create villains as
well as heroes.
The villains are the losers.
We have war criminals and
war criminals always turn out to be on the
side of the losers.
>> The Commission sentenced [UNKNOWN] to
be shot to death with [UNKNOWN].
>> It's very important to have those,
to attribute the historical events, to the
evil intentions of individuals.
>> [SOUND] Thus the stories of history are
cast in terms of the actions and
intentions of leaders.
Such stories are universal.
>> But so also is skepticism about them.
War and Peace argues that leadership is a
myth by which both leaders and
followers simplify a history that is too
complex for them to comprehend.
>> [FOREIGN].
>> Andrea Bokonski muses about leaders and
their successes.
>> [FOREIGN]
>> I don't know what is meant
by an able general.
>> Well, one that foresees the adversary's
intentions.
>> That's really quite impossible for
the most part since the adversary never
knows them himself.
>> Yeah.
Huh.
Yet they say that war is like a game of
chess.
>> Mm.
Who says it?
The people who fight wars from armchairs?
In chess you can think of a move as long
as you like,
in war one doesn't have that luxury.
In chess, the knight is always stronger
than a pawn, and
two pawns are always stronger than one.
In war, a battalion is sometimes stronger
than a division.
>> You get into battles like Fallujah and
there was no internal coherency.
Because you had different sets of actors
with different
power institutions behind them who weren't
talking to one another at all.
The insurgency was a bottom-up affair
being fought at the corporal level, and
the corporals actually had a better
understanding of what they're up
against than many other generals, but no
general could ever admit that.
>> [UNKNOWN]
>> So, as a consequence, we went through a
series of generals over
there who were really out of touch with
what was going on.
It was remarkable to be out there and
have the opportunity of being again with
the corporals out on the lines.
And then going back to talk to the
generals and, and
seeing this huge disconnect.
Let alone when you tried to go the
civilian level,
that supposedly were above the generals,
and they,
they did not have the slightly idea of
what was going on in the battle field.
>> Are they still there?
>> Yes sir, the Russians are still there.
>> Napoleon is puzzled by the way in which
the battle of Borodino comes to an end
without his orders.
>> I hear no sound.
Battle?
>> No sir, the fighting has ceased.
>> I gave no orders.
>> They just seem to have stopped of their
own accord.
>> After Borodino, General Kutuzov
patiently explains to his generals, that
no matter what they wish the Russian Army
will not respond to an order to attack.
>> I saw we can.
It needs but a small extra effort.
>> But a small extra effort, in killed and
wounded we have lost a third of our force.
And for what?
>> We have stopped them on the road to
Moscow.
>> [INAUDIBLE] We are not strong enough to
stop them, and
we do not need to stop them.
[MUSIC]
>> In Moscow, we talked to Nikolai
[UNKNOWN] the leading Tolstoy scholar,
about the theory of history in War and
Peace.
>> [FOREIGN].
>> Prometheus came.
>> Napoleon.
>> Yes that, those are the people.
>> The part of the Tolstoy this War and
Peace story that all narratives of history
are faults.
>> [FOREIGN].
>> Naturally.
>> No.
>> [FOREIGN]
>> And they're all true.
>> [FOREIGN].
>> All of them.
[LAUGH]
>> Because any narrative about history is
a story.
>> It seems to me that Napoleon is simply
a catalyst used by Tolstoy to comment on
history.
>> Yes, oh, absolutely, absolutely.
No, absolutely.
>> What are they talking about?
Is a man a military genius because he
knows when to order up the biscuits.
And Napoleon is no exception.
He thinks he commands a million men,
moving them here, there and everywhere.
But really he follows them.
They've not been brought to the borders of
Russia by him.
But by forces beyond our comprehension,
Napoleon is just a straw thrown to the
fall in the wind they make.
He's just a banner that they hold aloft.
>> Left wing, I think that's essential.
[NOISE].
>> Rather then living in world's in which
the causes of outcomes are clear and
the definitions of success and failure are
unproblematic, leaders live in
worlds in which causality is unclear and
the evaluation of outcomes is ambiguous.
>> There she is lying at my feet, awaiting
her destiny,
strange, beautiful, adjusting.
But why is it taking so
long for the municipal delegation to come
and pay its respects?
>> [NOISE] Rather than living in a world
in which there is a tight
coupling between problems and solutions,
between information and
action, leaders live in a world in which
those linkages are elusive.
>> [FOREIGN] [FOREIGN].
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> In spite of the unpredictabilities of
the daily world, War and
Peace extols the beauties of ordinary
life.
[SOUND].
>> According to Tolstoy's logic.
>> Mm-hm.
>> The true beauty is inside people's-
>> Yes.
>> Minds, and, and inside their souls.
They do what they should do and that's why
they're
spiritual beauty is the only the only true
beauty.
>> Do you love me?
>> Oh, yes, yes.
>> Countess Natalya Rostova and
Prince Andrei Bolkonsky have fallen in
love, and he has proposed to her.
[MUSIC]
>> What is it?
Is something wrong?
>> I feel so happy.
>> Now Prince Andrei no longer felt the
same love for her as before.
Something within him had changed.
There was none of the former poetic charm
of attraction, only a kind of pity for
her feminine and childish weakness.
>> Absurdity permeates critical
relationships-
>> [FOREIGN].
>> In peace, and in war.
For Natasha's brother Nikolai engaging in
his first battle [SOUND], events and
their causes seem disconnected.
>> [SOUND] What is it?
I don't move.
I fell.
I'm killed.
Who are these people?
Are they really the French?
O God, You who are in this sky!
Forgive, save and protect me!
Are they really coming to me?
What for?
To kill me?
Yes, they may kill me.
Me, who is loved by everyone?
[SOUND].
>> I think that Tolstoy is still accurate
because there's a desire for
self-heroism, [SOUND] and that's what they
focus upon.
[SOUND] They don't focus upon the mud and
the blood and the mistakes and the things
that they did wrong.
You very rarely hear about them.
They, they focus on those moments when
there was a clear challenge and
they overcame it.
So we do have a tendency as-
>> [COUGH]
>> Human beings to, to compartment what
we want to remember, or at least what we
wanna share with anybody else.
[SOUND].
>> In War and Peace, there are no heroes.
>> What shall we fire, Captain?
>> Nothing.
A shell!
>> The characters struggle with the
absurdity of life.
[SOUND] There is no reliable link between
actions and consequences.
The virtuous are not rewarded.
>> Captain Tushin, you've been ordered to
fall back.
>> Tushin's battery is effective in
battle, but
he is denounced to Prince Bagration.
>> How was it that the artillery was
abandoned?
>> I don't know, Your Excellency.
>> In Iraq, no one has failed.
I mean, every general has done brilliantly
and
been promoted and yet we've changed
strategy four times.
[LAUGH].
Now this is one reason why you don't find
much learning there.
Because if those who've come before, who
haven't done well, are promoted and
they're now your senior, you're not going
to criticize what they did.
You just change the strategy.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Well this, this doesn't make a lot of
sense.
And then the President gives medals of
freedom to people who've screwed up.
>> I had no men, Your Excellency.
>> Tushin is rescued by Andrei Bolkonsky,
who demands that justice be done.
>> Your Excellency!
You sent me to Captain Tushin's battery
today.
I found two thirds of his me and
his horses knocked out, two of his guns
disabled, and no covering troops at all.
And if Your Excellency will permit me to
give my opinion,
we owe today's success mainly to the
action of that battery and
the heroic endurance of Captain Tushin and
his company.
[SOUND]
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Captain Tushin, you may go.
>> Thank you so much, my friend.
You saved me.
>> Perhaps Captain Tushin deserves a
medal, but he will never get one.
>> Tushin had confidence.
He knew how to do what he did and he did
it well.
>> He's on the side of his friends who are
rationals.
>> Yes, yes.
>> Not, not much more.
>> And that's all.
>> He's going to do a good job.
>> When he deals with the higher
authorities, they ignore him.
>> He's not solving problems.
>> Yes.
>> It's they who are solving it.
>> From history's point of view they're
nothing.
>> Tushins, many Tushins.
>> Tushins.
>> Not one Tushin, but Tushin apart.
>> Yes, yes, yes.
>> In War and Peace, history is not made
by individual heroes,
little people, or leaders.
On the eve of the Borodino battle,
Andrei ridicules Pierre's idea that a
skilled commander can make a difference.
>> [FOREIGN].
>> He says, what faces us tomorrow?
A hundred million of the most varied
possibilities,
which'll be decided instantly, by who
runs, or will run, away.
Theirs or ours.
By whether this one, or that, is killed.
>> Look, that one almost blasted our
gentleman's hat off.
>> The basic idea.
History involves a complex system of
interacting actors and actions [SOUND].
War and Peace tells us unnoticed causes
are important.
Some phenomena might be predictable, but
not controllable.
Why did Moscow burn?
Not because specific people ignited it,
but because people abandoned it.
Once abandoned, it would burn.
>> So, the idea of objective in my own
writing of history.
>> Yes.
>> I realized at a certain point that I
had come to an impossible point.
I could write no more because I could not
document and
confirm everything, which was the standard
you're being forced against.
At some point historians have to become
fiction writers.
And good history has an element of fiction
in it, it has too.
The issue is how much you struggle for
objectivity and how you can weave a series
of, of views together.
>> Leave that woman alone!
>> History is absurd.
After Pierre Bezukhov is capture in
Moscow,
the french officer interrogating him is
called to eat.
So he casually sends his Pierre to be
shot.
[MUSIC]
The military judicial commission sentences
the accused to death by shooting [SOUND].
>> Leave the fat one!
>> But ultimately Pierre, for no
observable, reason is spared.
>> Don't!
>> War and Peace tells us that history
cannot be controlled by individuals.
Innocence is better than cleverness.
Passivity is better than ambition.
Figueres who appear in history cannot be
important [SOUND].
>> How can you not be afraid, sir?
>> And are you afraid?
>> How else could it be?
>> It won't forgive you.
It'll blow your guts out.
[LAUGH].
>> These generals displayed here in front
of the battle of
Borodino museum are major Russian heroes
of the battle.
These cannon, on the other hand, are
reminders of
the overlooked importance of minor people
doing their jobs well.
In War and Peace, ordinary competence in
mundane manners
is pictured as more significant than
genius in command.
The quiet competence of the artillery
officer Tushin,
this contrasted with the bombast of
irrelevant generals.
In a modern world, ordinary competence is
found in the bureaucrats, the rules,
the complex networks of organizations.
We're at Copenhagen Business School, and
I'm visiting Marianne Risberg, who's an
Academic Administrative something.
>> Yeah, officer.
>> Officer, yes.
And I visited this school for something
like 35 years, and
when I asked people who is indispensable,
they don't mention the dean,
or the rector, they mention Marianne
Risberg.
>> What do you do, Marianne?
>> What do I do?
It's not just one thing.
It's many, many things.
I know whom to call when it, for a
specific piece of information.
>> Mm-hm.
So
you have a network of contacts around the
school.
>> Yes.
>> You've been here 20 years, ever since
you were three years old, as I understand.
>> Yes, yes.
>> So you have a memory of what has
happened and how it happened and how to do
things.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And if they had a problem they called
up Marianne and
said, this is a problem, do something
about it.
>> Yeah.
>> And.
>> We have leaders and we have what you
would refer to only as the little people.
>> Yeah.
>> But I see it as a kind of division of
knowledge.
Because,.
>> [LAUGH] You have all of it and they
have-
>> No, not necessarily, but it's division,
I know, I, I have knowledge of,
of a certain area, and they have of a
different area.
And none of us can actually do without one
another.
>> Mm-hm.
By connecting disparate parts of the
institution's strengths,
Marianne's networks help to build the
school's capabilities.
[MUSIC]
Another person building capabilities is
Susan Erb.
Susan has been teaching first grade at
Park Day School for 33 years.
>> What's so bad about CO2, says
Templeton.
>> it's-
>> What's so bad about CO2?
>> If there's too much we would die
because if we kept breathing it,
it's really bad for us.
So the leaves suck it in so, and they let
out it, oxygen so-
>> You're both friends-
>> In the world of War and Peace, leaders
are unimportant.
But culture, and
shared values, are essential elements of a
nation's capabilities.
>> That's a strategy.
What were you gonna do?
>> In the modern world, many of those
capabilities are produced by millions of
teachers, like Susan Erb, working in
schools.
>> I need family, friends, food, and
water, peace in the world, and oxygen.
And I want [INAUDIBLE].
>> Susan molds the basic building blocks
of culture in her first graders.
Self knowledge, understanding the physical
world, and
the ability to get along with others in
the community.
>> It's really up to you two.
>> Break the record!
>> Have we broken the rules in awhile?
>> No.
>> Ok, ready, here we go.
We're not there.
[SOUND] Shh, they're doing something
important.
They're breaking the rules.
>> In the world view of War and
Peace, Susan Erb, like Marianne Risberg in
Copenhagen and Captain Tushin,
are part of the throng of millions of
competent people who really make history.
These people who make a difference are
connected in
complex social networks that give
structure to an apparently chaotic world
[MUSIC]
The Russian society of War and Peace is
based on elaborate networks of family and
personal connections, thus the emphasis in
the novel on arranging marriages,
on exploiting connections and, of course,
on this [UNKNOWN].
>> I hear you have Pierre Bezukhov staying
with you.
>> Well since he inherited Bezukhov's
estate,
I thought it my duty to take him under my
wing.
>> I do hope his manners have improved.
>> So rich nobody notices anymore.
[LAUGH].
>> There's Lisa Bolkonskaya now.
>> Hm, adorable!
>> It is not hard to imagine in these
beautiful rooms,
in the Yusupov Palace in St. Petersburg, a
social gathering at which
gossip would be exchanged, and favors
would be sought and granted.
It was in places such as this that the
intricate
networks of aristocratic Russian life were
elaborated and maintained.
The primary instruments for maintaining
one's position in
the Russian social order of War and Peace
are marriage and inheritance.
>> He won't survive a third stroke.
[MUSIC]
You know, Katishe that you and my wife are
his only direct heirs.
It's painful I know, still one must talk.
>> I never ceased praying to God that he'd
be merciful.
>> Still we must be ready.
I sent for Pierre, you know.
Well, he asked for him.
>> What does he want him for?
He's illegitimate, he can't inherit
anything.
>> I've tried to explain to you before,
all the old count had to do was to
write a letter to the Czar, begging him to
make Pierre legitimate.
>> With Prince Vasili's help, Pierre
receives his inheritance.
Vasili then manipulates the newly wealthy
young man into marrying his
daughter Helene.
It's going to happen.
I know it.
They're all expecting it.
They're so certain it will happen.
I can't disappoint them.
>> Well.
>> Nothing.
>> [NOISE]
My dear boy.
Thank god.
My wife has just told me.
Oh my, I'm so happy.
I knew your father.
I loved him I must say.
Oh, you make her such a good wife.
My little girl.
My little Elaine.
Eileen, Eileen, Anna come here.
Oh this is wonderful, wonderful.
>> War and Peace portrays a world
permeated with falsity.
It is not however a world of chaos.
Aristocratic, family networks and a stable
peasant culture infused Russian life.
[MUSIC]
These elements bring to the unfolding of
history an overall capability,
the General Kutuzov often called Mother
Russia.
[MUSIC]
War and Peace pictures peasant life and
traditions as the core of Russian
strength.
>> Oh but you should see what a fine job
they made of the old place now.
A yard full of livestock.
A field full of oats.
Two other brothers earning wages.
[LAUGH] It's a treat to go home to.
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> The peasant brings a culture of
elementary values and
knowledge that transcends the cleverness
and pretensions of leadership.
[MUSIC]
>> Behind me sits [INAUDIBLE] a Russian
village of old believers located about
a 1,000 kilometers northeast of Moscow,
and
about 500 kilometers west of the Ural
Mountains.
It consists of about 45 occupied houses,
with about 100 people.
We've come here in search of Mother
Russia,
that mysterious combination of habits,
patience, and
confidence that describes the culture of
traditional peasant life.
In War and Peace the Russian General
Kutuzov, views Mother Russia
both as a teacher and as an ally in his
struggles against the French.
>> [FOREIGN]
>> You have to be able to curse a blue
streak here, and be able to drink.
Yeah, they taught me how to swear of
course.
>> [FOREIGN]
>> The essence of peasant living in
endurance through the turnover of regimes.
>> [FOREIGN].
>> Peasant life is buffeted by change but
it allows the waves of monarchs and
masters to pass over it while holding on
to the ability to survive.
[MUSIC]
>> [FOREIGN].
>> I can't be without the Earth.
It's the thing that feeds us.
It's our birth mother.
How my heart pours out.
Everything now is fallow.
I cry.
I can't sleep at night.
Look my hair
is turning gray, it's just awful.
>> [FOREIGN].
>> He used a huge, he used an old Samovar
with you know,
with the [UNKNOWN]
>> [FOREIGN]
>> Because his own honey.
>> Done.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> War and Peace
offers numerous minor critiques of peasant
life.
>> [FOREIGN]
>> But
one of the books main themes is a
throughly romantic portrayal
of the peasant, his abilities, and his
connection to the land.
>> [FOREIGN]
>> We never lived in the city.
>> You know for me it's always been the
power of nature.
Where I was born, our cabin was right next
to the woods.
>> [FOREIGN].
>> He was born just like Jesus Christ, in
a manger, in the hay with the sheep.
>> My mother gave birth.
>> It was a big family.
>> My father really loved nature and
he passed it along to us as an inheritance
through our genes, and I love nature too.
When I was just a kid, he gave me a little
ax, an ax, and
as we were walking, I chipped at the trees
in the woods with it.
He was very strict and said don't ever do
that, ever.
>> [FOREIGN]
>> I'm ashamed before nature if I
take heedlessly.
I gather all the twigs I knock down for
firewood.
And then I feel good.
[MUSIC]
>> [FOREIGN].
>> There was war, there was famine.
This icon here is from my mother.
The icon of Jesus, she set it up for me
and my sister and
said, say your prayers to Jesus girls.
>> [FOREIGN]
>> And she would, and
she would tell us, to me and my sister.
>> Our father died, he died of hunger.
We're crying and praying how could it not
help us.
>> What did people do.
>> [FOREIGN].
>> We ate other things leaves, we
collected grasses.
>> There was famine.
>> [FOREIGN].
>> People have their own households.
Whoever keeps a cow lives well.
That's how we survived.
Whoever loves the land lives off it.
And if you don't love the land and till
it, then it's all over.
>> [FOREIGN].
[MUSIC]
>> It it not necessary to accept the
romantic peasant mystique,
to recognize the more general point that
leadership involves developing and
using the values and spirit of a culture.
[MUSIC]
In defeating the invading French, General
Kutuzov depended on
the spirit of Russian peasants, and their
capacity to survive.
That spirit finds expression in dance.
[NOISE] This is the rehearsal hall of the
song and
dance ensemble of the Russian army in St.
Petersburg, a group of soldiers and
civilians who perform traditional Russian
dances.
[NOISE].
>> [FOREIGN].
>> It's really from very long ago.
The whole history of Russia is connected
to these dances.
Our grandfathers all of them and our great
grandfathers they all danced.
The Russian spirit supports it, it
improves your self esteem.
[MUSIC]
>> [FOREIGN].
>> Unfortunately now it's become rarer,
even in the villages,
to see real people dance Russian folk
dance who haven't studied it specially.
So we are trying, somehow, to preserve
what our ancestors did.
[MUSIC]
>> My father's a dance master.
My brother and grandfather were both
artists.
It's like I've gone down the family path.
[MUSIC]
>> [FOREIGN].
>> It's the soul, that's where it comes
from.
Without this, a Russian is not a Russian.
>> Theres another theme in the War on
Peace,
of the importance of the competency of
ordinary people.
That history is, is created by [COUGH]
complex combinations of
a lot of ordinary people doing their jobs.
>> We talked with sociologist Joel
Padolme, Dean of the Yale School of
Management, to get his perspective on
leadership, capabilities and networks.
>> It's one of the unfortunate facts of
the modern literature on leadership that
we do tend to over-play the importance of
a single individual, the heroic leader.
History gives a leader certain artifacts
with which to work.
And one of those artifacts is clearly the
pattern of relationships,
the networks that exists.
A savvy leader is going to know that she
or
he is going to be a lot more effective if
she tries to understand
what's the, what's the underlying fabric
of relationships.
And then sort of work with that fabric.
[SOUND].
>> War and Peace argues that heroic
leadership has little to do
with the unfolding of history.
However the novel hints at a different
role for leaders.
Russian aristocratic society at the
beginning of the 19th
century was a network of extended families
connected by reciprocal favors.
In such a society effective leadership
involves exploiting social networks for
the capabilities they offer.
>> That perspective has overtones in
the 15th century history of Renaissance
Florence.
And we've come to Florence now to talk
with Professor John Pageant,
a leading scholar of the 15th century
Florentine world of Cosimo de' Medici.
[MUSIC]
>> Cosimo de' Medici did not begin with a
grand plan to take over the state.
Rather events sort of swept him into
power.
It was his networks, his banking networks
that made Venice so happy to see him come,
family networks that pulled the people in
the street, all these sort of
organizational networks [UNKNOWN]
capabilities, you might call them.
It didn't allow him to initiate action,
but
definitely allowed him to respond to
action.
Now there a number of perspectives from
which you can view Cosimo de' Medici.
The basis of his economic power, was the
fact that he was a banker to the Pope.
But he translated this Papal connection
into organizational capacity, and
he funded all sorts of international trade
throughout Europe.
This room is very similar to what the
account book room
of the Medici bank would have looked like.
The Florentine bankers and their social
networks are,
it transfers through which customers all
over Europe are conducting their business.
[MUSIC]
Is it of great deal of trust and security
involved that has to be established for
this system to work.
Account books exist as a, as a sign, as a
symbol, so each of these pages is actually
a social network, it's a person with whom
the, the banker is doing business.
[MUSIC]
>> One of the most familiar scenes in War
and Peace is people waiting outside
an influential person's door, to seek
favors or to bring information or
to tell them that they are their friends,
that's the way the social structure works.
We're in Florence outside of Cosimo de
Medici's house.
I'm sitting on the bench where similar
people would have sat in the 15th century.
Waiting to bring things to Cosimo.
Waiting to ask him for favors.
Waiting to enter into the basic game of
the social network that Cosimo presided
over.
[MUSIC]
>> Jim we are here in the private chapel
of the Palazzo de' Medici.
In other words, in the inner sanctum of
Cosimo's own home.
It's the Journey of the Magi.
The image of the Magi became developed,
you might say, as the mythology that de'
Medici used to present themselves to their
fellow citizens of Florence.
Cosimo de' Medici, the gentleman on the
donkey, probably thinks of
himself also as a humble man, in spite of
his incredible wealth and power.
So-
>> Donkey with guilded
trekkings of course.
>> Good point.
>> [LAUGH].
>> And a precession of a journey of the
Medici chief family going back.
Through time to this castle up there on
the hill.
And going forward in time through
following the, the Magi to the baby Jesus.
So to understand the process of
constructing family, and by extension
political alliances, it is quite important
to think about this practice of giving.
Gift exchange, food, money,
building, this is the raw materials, the
raw organizational practices,
if you will that the Florentines used to
build, their networks.
[MUSIC]
I think in the Medici story that Paget
tells so well.
I mean, the real brilliance that's there
is him recognizing, that in point of fact,
if you build a network that is goal
directed, it has two problems.
One, it's very costly.
Because in order to get people to sign up
for
that they know exactly the terms that they
can extract.
Two, if your goals or
your interests ever shift, then you've
created this very narrowly defined
network that's now focused on doing this
when you want to go in in that direction.
[MUSIC]
Seems to me there are two sort of basic
ways in which people try to
make themselves endure.
The first is family.
Through a family, your genetic and
cultural trace goes to your children, and
from your children to their children, and
then so on and
so on, through the generations.
The second major way, is through the
artifacts we create.
We make various forms of art.
Painting, sculpture, writings of various
sorts.
And buildings.
The various things that we call, art.
And these endure long [UNKNOWN].
Now Cosimo obviously was involved in both
of these.
Is there any contemporaneous evidence that
he was concerned
either about his relevance to history or
about his mortality?
>> Actually Jim the answer to that is very
much yes.
According to Vespasiano,
he thought that people would never
remember him five years after he died.
The only way that they would remember him
is through this art and these buildings,
in particularly these buildings that he
made to influence his children,
the grandchildren, us.
The building La Cupola, the dome in the
middle, was not started by Cosimo but
was finished by Cosimo.
San Lorenzo was actually renovated and
beautified by Cosimo.
Badia the abbey and monasteries in the
hills were made by Cozomo.
He made his palaces and started an entire
palace movement.
So if you put all of these things
together, banker, statesman, patron,
I think you have the conclusion and the
image of a Renaissance man.
And Cosimo started a regime,
the Medicean regime that lasted almost
four centuries with one small break.
>> In some sense you have a kind of goal
free problem solving.
You are creating an institution or
creating some capabilities or creating
some answers without quite knowing what
the questions are going to be.
>> There is this idea with vision that
it's always about looking forward.
But I think if you look at the really
powerful visions that get developed to
lead groups, to lead social movement,
they're typically visions
that are grounded in a very strong sense
of common identity, with strong historical
roots and what the, what the leader has
done is to interpret that for everybody.
And that act of interpretation actually
becomes the basis for
building and reinforcing the network.
>> In many ways that's General Kutuzov in
War and Peace.
He talks about the soul of Mother Russia.
[MUSIC]
[FOREIGN].
>> In War and Peace, advance planning and
strategies to
change the course of history are pictured
as the pretenses of foolish leaders.
>> [FOREIGN].
>> General Kutuzov's wisdom on the other
hand,
involves going with the flow of history.
>> [FOREIGN].
>> [NOISE]
[FOREIGN].
>> [FOREIGN].
>> At Austerlitz he knows all the well
laid plans are for naught.
After Bordeno, Kutuzoff retreats and waits
patiently for Mother Russia to prevail.
[NOISE].
>> [FOREIGN].
>> [FOREIGN]
Napoleon has left Moscow?
Huh?
>> [FOREIGN].
>> In contemporary terms Kutuzov's wisdom
is mystical or instinctive.
>> [FOREIGN].
>> Comprehension cannot be sought.
It comes in great random moments that
cannot be anticipated.
>> How peaceful.
>> In bringing about a result-
>> In that spirit, General Kutuzov
abandons claims of self-importance and
accepts the ironies of life and history.
>> Why did you not pursue the French
across the frontier?
>> My instructions were to expel the
invader from our soil.
>> Can you really be said to have
accomplished your objectives by halting
arbitrarily at the frontiers of our
country?
You have expelled the enemy from Russia.
Now it is for us to take over and continue
your great work.
And from now on, I shall assume command of
the army, myself.
[SOUND].
[MUSIC]
>> War and
Peace scorns those who imagine acting
decisively in pursuit of a grand plan.
It venerates those who are strong enough
to be patiently passive.
And it praises those who can take
advantage of
whatever strengths they may have.
[MUSIC]
[SOUND].
Like Kutuzov, Cosimo de' Medici positioned
himself to take advantage of the winds,
rather than trying to sail against them.
He built capabilities without anticipating
clearly what would be done with them.
Cosimo spent part of each day meditating
in his cell at the San Marco monastery.
[SOUND].
>> The entry point that all monks and
Cosimo himself would arrive at-
>> This [UNKNOWN] angelical painting of
the enunciation,
which Cosimo commissioned, greeted him
every day on the way to his cell.
>> In this particular awesome place.
>> Mary is listening very hard to what the
angel is saying.
And this is the attitude that monks ought
to put on
when they enter this particular
establishment.
[MUSIC]
Mary is listening.
The angel is talking, or
trying to pick up what the angel is saying
by listening to himself.
[MUSIC]
>> Perhaps leaders do not change the
course of history but they construct
the buildings and commission the art and
architecture that enhances our lives.
Cosimo de' Medici was the patron of the
great Florentine sculptor Donatello.
This room is filled with objects produced
by
Donatello during his life as a client of
Cosimo de' Medici.
[MUSIC]
War and Peace tells us that beauty is
found not only in the high art of
great artists, but also in the textures of
everyday life.
[MUSIC]
Beauty is found in the hunt, in sleigh
rides.
In dance.
[MUSIC]
And in family relations.
>> [FOREIGN].
>> In modern life, beauty is found in a
Florentine restaurant,
where Giuseppe Alessi recreates recipes
from the 15th century.
He imbues them not only with extraordinary
flavors, but also with his enthusiasm.
>> [FOREIGN] I use the power of fire.
My relationship with fire is based on
conflict,
because clearly fire devours everything.
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> I have to dominate the fire, and
beat it back with iron, to make the food
just right.
>> Beauty is found within the harsh
wartime life of a Russian village.
>> [FOREIGN] And the war was still going
on, but it makes me want to cry.
We had nothing to wear.
There was nothing to eat.
Then they sent us packages to the town
here.
Even today I can remember the taste of
that sugar.
[MUSIC]
So when America sent us some rags, we were
very happy.
Even today I remember there was a checked
skirt with a very fine check.
And whenever I see that kind of material
immediately I remember.
[FOREIGN].
>> In fact I remember almost all of-
This was my brother's shirt.
I can remember that.
I can remember that this was a skirt that
my mom wore it.
But a lot of these pieces on here I
remember.
>> Beauty is found in the attitude toward
life of Oran Ohl,
who makes quilts to restore good feelings
after the deaths of victims of
urban violence, including two of her own
sons.
[MUSIC]
Well I'm so glad you guys came.
And now you know how to redirect that
inner anger.
Once you turn it in, let it out.
See what I did?
I let it all out.
Now its all out there for the public to
see.
It didn't hurt anybody, right?
If anything, it helps.
So you can always find something to do to
redirect that inner pain and
make it into something good.
Don't let it stay in there.
Find something to get it out.
You know, in a positive way.
[MUSIC]
War and Peace tells us that the passion,
the serenity, and the elementary
grace of millions of ordinary people
create the beauty of everyday life.
This room, in the Yusupov palace in St.
Petersburg.
Is a reminder that War and
Peace embraces an aesthetic response to
the images and experiences of life.
No where is the dedication of War and
Peace to beauty more evident than in the
character of Natasha Rostova.
>> Tolstoy is obviously in love with
Natasha Rastova.
>> It's true.
>> She's frivolous.
She's narcissistic.
She's self-indulgent.
And yet, he's in love with her.
>> But she's natural.
>> She is natural.
You know?
>> The main idea of Tolstoy, Tolstoy is to
be natural.
>> Yeah.
>> Everything unnatural as, as Napoleon,
as Helen.
>> Yes.
yes.
That's right.
>> While scorning attempts to better the
world,
the novel is enthusiastic about the
beauties of daily life.
[MUSIC]
The book's message in its affection for
Natasha is that the elements of beauty
found in ordinary life are important.
Perhaps in some small way, leaders can
contribute to recognizing and
increasing that beauty.
[MUSIC]
This is the Copenhagen Business School, a
site that combines architecture and
art to create one of the more beautiful
academic environments in the world.
Fin Yungayenson, the long-time rector of
CBS, is an old friend of mine.
He combines a taste for classical objects
of art with a sense of
the importance of creating a milieu that
stimulates an aesthetic experience.
>> One of the conspicuous things about CBS
is the art and architecture.
You've built some very striking buildings.
Why?
>> I think that forms an environment which
gives
inspiration opportunities because we are
living in it and living as part of it.
And it makes for more enthusiastic,
dedicated students who feel themselves
more or less at home here.
It creates an environment which, makes for
curiosity.
If you cannot create environments where
you also stimulate inspiration,
things you cannot explain, emotions which
are of a variety of kinds.
Then you do not develop, entrepreneurs,
people who do things differently.
>> What I hear you say is that a beautiful
setting of architecture and art
creates a beautiful community and, even if
I could use the term, beautiful people.
>> It creates, at least, more suitable
conditions for
the development of beautiful activities
and people.
Of course, there's no, guarantee,
unfortunately.
But, but still it stimulates a sense of
doing things at a high level
because it speaks to your senses and your
non-conscious ways of thinking.
>> I think it is as important to recognize
that there
are essential elements of beauty.
>> No, I wouldn't-
>> As there are to recognize there are
essential answers in Mathematics.
>> Right.
>> I'm glad.
We agree.
Beauty reigns above all.
[LAUGH].
>> It's only the beauty that we, they have
on way that makes any difference.
>> Okay, let's drink to the beauty.
>> To beauty.
[FOREIGN]
[MUSIC]
>> [FOREIGN].
>> The earth, the earth it feeds us.
It gives all.
You just have to lay your hands to it.
And there will be fertility, and there
will be everything.
>> I will never forget the law of in
brotherhood that was between him and me.
>> That's a very interesting question how
such
a friendshipped created world was
constructed.
So crucial to the liquidity of Europe.
When in fact, people in general don't
trust each other.
>> [NOISE].
>> It's about your kiss.
Your kiss is, as hot as a pancake.
[MUSIC]
>> War and
Peace ensures us that heroic stories of
leaders are the work of our imagination.
These fables of heroic leaders give
pleasure.
They can be admired and repeated without
accepting them as reality.
History is not made by leaders.
It is made by millions and millions of
peasants and first grade teachers.
War and Peace argues that the
effectiveness of
an organization depends less on heroic
leadership than on myriads of
common people organized into complex
social networks and doing their jobs well.
[MUSIC]
It depends on enduring cultures that
nourish and reproduce those capabilities.
[MUSIC]
>> Leadership involves allowing the
competence of ordinary people and
their networks to flower without trying to
strike heroic poses.
It involves creating objects and
surroundings of beauty and
encouraging individual contributions to
the elementary grace of everyday life.
>> That's where the sand is.
>> Yes.
>> If you want a darker blue, this is a
darker blue.
>> I left my doubts go, and I ate pancakes
with you all night.
[FOREIGN] [LAUGH] So it's not about
pancakes.
No Russian song is about pancakes.
In the world of War and Peace, truth and
beauty are precious.
But beauty is less elusive than truth.
[MUSIC]